[Music]
these Essenes were unlikely to see again
anytime soon as the world anti-doping
agency has banned Russia for four years
from global sports it means there'll be
no Russian team at the Olympics all
football World Cup no Russian national
anthem or Russian flag the country is
also forbidden from hosting or bidding
for major events this represents the
most severe sanction yet for a doping
scandal which shocked the world at the
height of the deception Russia's
cheating was worthy of a Hollywood
script dirty urine samples were passed
through a hole in the wall and swapped
the clean ones sought you into Olympics
in 2014 but this ban that pertains not
to the doping itself but the cover-up of
the cover-up data handed over from this
Moscow laboratory to water investigators
had been manipulated deleted and faked
these are the water executive members
who decided on that punishment where are
you surprised to see such critical and
the doping bethe
deleted by the Russians even after
they'd promised to be compliant the
answer is yes
surprised I mean why would we place an
offer before the Russian authorities to
break the deadlock that existed between
wada and russia the assumption was that
we were waiting entirely for russia to
accept the mclaren report russian
athletes competed as neutrals at the Rio
Olympics in 2016 and were welcomed back
into the international fold before this
new act of deception here in lisanna at
the home of the International Olympic
Committee and just behind me you can see
the countdown clock ticking down for the
Tokyo Olympics there are now 227 days to
go but as it stands there will be no
Russian team there although some
athletes may compete under a neutral
banner
and at home the ban was welcomed by
scores of British athletes cheated out
of medals by Russians the Great Britain
bobsleigh team was presented with
Devil's medal from Sochi last month five
years after the event
we definitely missed out I mean when we
first found out all of this went on it
there was definitely some anger and
disappointment towards the whole event
but eventually it just sort of turned
out that he dragged out so long we were
just relieved to get hold of the medal
you know and it hasn't sort of left my
side since you know we still got it here
and you know we're trying to just work
out what we're doing with it now and
making the most of it this isn't a
blanket ban on Russian athletes but
storm that still feel a sense of
persecution if we all want to play fair
and stand against doping then we should
deal with this problem together
otherwise some countries get sanctioned
for the use of doping whilst others
don't
six years after the first evidence of
widespread cheating in Russia and the
deception continues but with the country
likely to appeal this decision the ban
is not the end of the story Martha
Kellner Sky News lisanna